Christopher Nolan, as a filmmaker. His works always have subtle boundaries
If there is a theme throughout his work...
That is the movie, the so-called shared story. Can become a strong cultural influence
Many people have noticed that many of his works refer to the film production itself.
For example, the "full start" team is very similar to the film production team (director, art director, producer, actor)
Interestingly, many of his works can be called "post-screen movies".
Nolan tried to avoid the appearance of a movie in his work.
For example, when writing a Batman script. Bruce Wein and his parents
After watching the "masked man Sulu" in the cinema, the parents were murdered. Contributed to the origin of the Dark Knight
However, in "Batman: Wartime", I adapted to see Mefistofele at the Opera House.
This change is not without reason, as Nolan mentioned in the interview.
We decided not to let Bruce go to the cinema to see "masked man Sulu" because let the characters watch movies in the movie...
It’s totally different from watching a movie in a manga.
It will create something destructive. This is what we want to avoid.
The reason that Nolan wants to avoid is also the reason that is above everything. His film pursues "hiking the world"
Use the power of narrative to break the border and draw you into the story.
The subtle line of Nolan's work is to make you feel that it is a movie.
In other words, it is hidden in the eyes of the public.
Hidden in the eyes of the public is the fifth part of Nolan and my favorite work. The theme of "top showdown"
He uses this technique like a textbook. You can even call it "the ultimate in filmmaking."
In the words of Nolan, this movie makes you feel immersed and there is no destructive thing.
For example, the first continuous lens first comes into view with the movie title.
The mysterious shot behind the title is a lot of messy top hats in the woods.
If you read this movie, you will know that there is another meaning in this scene.
Because these top hats represent the movie "Top Showdown" itself (the title of The Prestige is the last step of the magic three steps, appeared.)
The second clue is that the number of hats is double, a large number of copies, and countless
This is the key to the magic tricks in the film. It also echoes in the second act.
a large number of identical canaries in a bird cage
Michael Kane begins to explain the magic trick
Each magic contains three parts, or actions. Take the virtual reality, steal the day, and finally... show up
This serial lens carefully sets the "virtual reality" of the movie itself.
Kristen Bell and Hugh Jackman play Effie Budan and Robert Angel
When Mi Gao Kenn performed magic on the little girl, the narration explained the method.
The movie itself is performing its own magic... using the cut.
Where did the narration come from?
In the movie, the narration is usually a matter of explaining something happening in the future.
At the end of the scene, the judge of the court who turned to the Bhutan murder was asking about Michael.
The last paragraph of Michael's explanation is his testimony.
We will not know until the end. Fragment of little girl and canary magic...
At the point in time, it is actually the end of the movie.
Nolan uses the narration and scene editing to convert the connection of time
This replacement is the key to the whole movie.
The top-of-the-line squad is all about magic with objects related to time and space.
This is exactly what all the movies are doing.
Most of the clips are made through simple cuts. Can connect "short distance" and "continuous time"
This is what most people think.
However, it is also a simple splicing. Nolan is able to cross "long distance" and "long time"
Nolan once mentioned that he saw the "red alert" directed by Terrence Malik and learned the skills of this technique.
In the film, Malik cuts the pieces of memories without blurring, fading out or ripples.
But it can resonate strongly with the audience.
The "Top Showdown" brings this skill to the ultimate in the editing of complex and intertwined memories.
Nolan uses the diaries of Budan and Angel as his means
When he built this technique, he could use narratives at any time, natural editing memories.
In this way, the "top confrontation" proves the unique ability of the film.
But you don't have to compromise with the audience, causing an unnatural feeling.
The complex narrative structure is the story that Nolan wants to tell.
The film must hide the secret until it is revealed to the audience.
This is the outstanding talent of Christopher Nolan as a filmmaker. Strong and powerful film narrative talent
He can use a lot of future elements to form a plot
Even giving you all the clues is not the last scene...
If the "top showdown" only allows us to learn these, I will call it a good movie.
But it's not just that there is a fragment, which is often ignored but conveys a focus.
He killed the bird. what?
No, he killed the bird.
did you see? He is fine, just here.
But where is his brother?
You can watch the "top showdown" and enjoy its storyline
It was Nolan's promise, and he wanted to surprise us.
The movie line also said: "The audience wants to be fooled."
But no matter what movie, even the narrative compact "top showdown", while you are immersed in the story, you can still be keen to observe.
Just as the boy understands the magic of the canary, we can also discover the mystery of the movie.
Of course, most of us are talking about editing skills but he is telling the story.
Any storytelling technique has deeply influenced the composition of our memories.
Whether shared or private
I just want to say that studying movies doesn’t ruin it’s incredible
Instead, you will feel that the incomprehensible parliament gives back to the real world.
Hello everyone, thank you for watching and thank you for sponsoring the film at Squarespace.
I am fortunate to be able to get help from Squarespace.
Thanks to all those who support me, so that I can create with all my heart.
Continue to do the videos I want to do, do my best to provide quality content.
Squarespace is really great
You can make a professional website without learning any code.
If you sign up for a year, you can get free space.
And today's squarespace.com has a trial period
Enter Nerdwriter for 10% off
Thank you all, we will see you next week!